[Music]
all right 20s now his first time on
Hannity he is the owner of the Dallas
Mavericks and the hit show shark tank
one of the co I love that show it's a
great show more Cuban how are you sir
I'm doing great shot thanks for having
me on all right I have a plan to reopen
the NBA and I want to throw it by you
and I've been talking a lot on other
owners of other sports franchises Robert
Kraft Randy Levine all those guys okay
so the way maybe you can play basketball
outside every single person that works
in the whatever the stadium what
wherever the game is being held they
have to have the Cova test that day one
of the Abbott tests which are now more
available than ever before you take that
you have a temperature I'll show you
this thing on the screen it's called a
temperature turnstile you walk through
it you take the temperature you have a
high temperature you're not allowed
admission then we have this really cool
mask that people will get if they go
watch the Dallas Mavericks
and it's a Dallas Mavericks basketball
mask to keep people safe if you want to
go to the game you gotta wear the mask
just like the medical manufacturers did
and the guys that stock the shelves in
New York and you can drink beer through
a straw maybe eat a hotdog if you put
your mask on quick thoughts would that
work we played games outside before so
you're in the right direction there it's
obviously a lot safer to do it outside
I'm not as big a fan as the temperature
check because if you just eat three
quick extra-strength Tylenol you can
beat those tests but we're getting to
that point Sean where we're going to be
able to do some testing and hopefully be
able to play games I don't think we're
ready for fans yet but let's take that
first step I think we can get that so
what if you did every other scene if you
get a big stadium right let's say in the
equivalent of Yankee Stadium whatever
well we get to where we can have fans we
can quarantine group people together
right so if you're the family if the
Hannity family comes together we don't
need to put seats between all of them
the Cuban family Hannity family of
foreign team together we can quarantine
group people together but we have to
take our first steps first to make sure
all the plans that we have or
effectively things yeah listen I want
that sports are a big part of the
American culture
psychic I'm willing to wear a mask to go
I will wear it I'll go through anything
else I'll drink my beer through a straw
all right now you said about Donald
Trump I want to ask you about this is
you said you're supporting Biden and you
said you would prefer him okay
he's you know I don't have a problem if
we have different politics let's start
with coronavirus alone you tell me all
all the things bunker Joe did on
coronavirus that you admire and then
I'll tell you what I think Trump did is
that I admire let's start that way well
Joe's not in charge of anything right
now right he's the candidate you know so
he can't really put him in that category
but Shawn I'll listen okay what do you
think I mean what have we got to lose
to listen to what you said that Donald
did right yep but the point is okay he
wouldn't he called the travel ban now
Donald Trump will you give him credit
ten days after the first known case of
corona in America credit there are teens
first in 50 years for subsequent travel
bans good ideas yeah okay we all know
the models and the medical professionals
were wrong and I'm not blaming them
China lied to the world that's a
predicted but they're not supposed to be
100% accurate they're supposed to be
guidelines
okay so Trump build all the hospitals in
New York he built senta's Navy hospital
ship he said every ventilator every
shield every mask gloves gowns
everything because New York was prepared
for nothing and he got that even
converted those hospitals to Copa 19
capability now you went on saying that
Donald Trump hasn't done a good job with
this I would argue he did a phenomenal
job and save New York's ass so here's
the problem so I was involved some of
those conversations and so what happened
was when PPE got into short supply what
I suggested that they do was match up
the demand along with the supply but
they wouldn't do that right so no one
would take inventory of where all the
PPP was around the country and because
they wouldn't present that market
information Hospital started hoarding
and we didn't know where the
manufacturing resources were coming from
so we got into even more a greater short
supply of PPE the White House had the
opportunity to fix that they knew they
could have fixed it but they didn't take
the actual steps because no one was
truly in charge the president Trump
really had it he had the right idea and
putting the people in charge but he had
one group doing one thing another group
doing other things they tell you that's
not true New York New York Governor
Cuomo hang on
in November of 2015 his own task force
said in peak week you'll be shy fifteen
thousand seven hundred eighty-three
ventilators New York Mayor comrade de
Blasio who said they needed 10,000 they
had nothing absolutely nothing
now Jerry mother managed every
ventilator they said every bit of
medical equipment they man the Javits
Center 3000 beds they man the the
hospital ship they built they converted
him and changed the ventilation systems
New York was dead without Donald Trump
that's just a fact so you're exactly
right on sharing what he did the problem
was Jared wasn't the only one working on
it
there were multiple groups working on
the same thing and that created
confusion are you right about New York
yes that they handled it correctly
no but could have been handled a lot
better absolutely Shawn and on top of
that when we started feeling with
ventilators and this is both the White
House and the state of New York well we
started getting all these ventilator
deaths
nobody did a thing there were people
there were reports saying that 88% of
people on ventilators were dying or that
yeah they were dying but no one at the
state level or the federal level from
the White House came out and said stop
using so many ventilators both parties
made mistakes and a constant people
they're lying but you can't ask the
White House to make medical decisions
for hospitals and doctors all right let
me ask you this because you said you're
supporting Biden which I don't under you
are too smart
I've watched you on shark tank you're
too good and too smart you're too good a
businessman and this doesn't make any
sense to me all right let me show you a
montage of your candidate and then you
tell me out of this montage that you're
gonna vote for this guy and explain why
I like to
I'm trying to understand your thinking
cuz I think a lot of you I think you're
a good owner for the NBA you can
outspoken entrepreneur you're a
capitalist here's Joe Biden your your
your choice for president just me good
evening thanks so much for tuning in
look tomorrow's superstar Suzy and I
want to thank you all I tell you what
I'm rushing ahead aren't I
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women created by a goal you
know the you know the thing you agree
with me
go to Joe 303 301 of the things I like
about Mark Cuban on Shark Tank is you
call it as it is now let me ask you Joe
Biden is the king of malok Ross but
Donnell our president had a ya know ya
know do you think that guy you know you
don't think this guy's had if he had a
fastball curveball slow pitch that
they're all gone
come on that's not scare you you know
what both sides scare me I'm not I'm not
gonna lie Sean Joe Biden scares me in
some areas and president Trump scares me
in war areas right now and I'll tell you
why because I think that Donald doesn't
put the best people in place then you
longer he did at the beginning I was
proud of him at the beginning but now he
won just wants people who are loyal to
him and that's a problem and has created
more problems in this pandemic well if
you had as many knives in your neck and
SHIVs in your neck like he's got you'd
probably want to fire those people too
but prior to kovat record low
unemployment for every demographic in
the country something Biden and Obama
never pulled off last word you know
there's no question he deserves a lot of
credit for what happened with the
economy he's done really well there but
those days are behind us now but he
can't be playing the victim all that you
know Sean this is what really bothers me
about the president he's the most
powerful man in the world
and he always plays the victim card the
Dems are out to get me the
Media is out to give me you gotta be the
leader you gotta be the strongest man in
the game have to shown that strand mark
that's what the mark they spied on the
guy they spied on a candidate his
transition team they spied on his
presidency those who build bars words
not Sean Hannity's who cares he's the
most powerful man in the world be
powerful be a leader and he fathered
Sean when you're he's supposed to be the
world's best counter puncher he hasn't
been able to knock anybody out he just
plays the victim look I love the way you
stand up all these people that call him
out that's a great thing Sean but the
man has got to be a leader and he hasn't
shown that yet you know one thing he's
never gonna do
he's Donald Trump he's he got elected as
Donald Trump he saved the country as an
idol Trump and he'll bring the country
back as Donald Trump but great sit next
to you during during the first game when
your your team opens up I'll sit next to
you and I won't bring any New York kovat
with me I promise I'll tell you what I
want to watch you eat that hot dog
through the math that's even better this
is what you do you take the mass you
shove it under you take a fighting and
you just gotta chew it you know but god
forbid if you get the pot dog you know
what that would be ugly but I'll drink
my beer through the straw all right Mark
Cuban amen